so you want to learn biology but you
don't know where to start well in this
video I'm going to tell you sex with a
books that I think are really good
beginning introductory books to biology
because let's be honest the Big B is a
big topic biology and it's hard to know
where to start and so I'm just going to
share some of my recommendations that
were really useful for me when I did my
undergrads and a levels and Masters and
now my phds so hopefully you'll also
find these books useful now biology is a
big topic ranges from how we gave from a
single cell to full organism to plants
to your immune systems to why we age and
why we die and speaking of living and
dying my first recommendation is how we
live and why we die The Secret Life of
cells by Lewis wilpert now there's a
reason why many universities have this
as a sort of preliminary reading
essential material for biology courses
basically because it's a really great
overview of a lot of Topics in biology
um it's a kind of a nice warm-up
introduction which is pretty accessible
for most people to read
and it ranges from talking about how
cells work together to introduce some
topics like development cancer and stem
cells and it even has a chapter on my
age whereas my feelings may find
interesting
and for sure like some of the
Technologies it talks about now are
probably a little bit out of date but
the core principles remain the same at
the end of the day this video is about
telling you what books provide you with
these core principles in biology that
once you have this Foundation you can
kind of dip into any sort of area of
Interest
now as a bonus book I'd also recommend a
similar book waterslife by Paul nurse
Paul nurse was involved in the discovery
of genes that play a really important
role in the cell cycle regulation and
then if none of those words made any
sense to you then you should probably
read this book and speaking of tunes the
next book I would recommend is
the gene by Siddhartha makaji and this
book is basically the story of the gene
an intimate history as the book says and
it really is an intimate history
um intimate in a sense that it goes
through all of the different events from
the first discovery of genes and the
concepts of genes and how genetic
materials inherited all the way through
to looking at the kind of implications
of understanding this kind of coding of
information in the genome and the crispr
and all these other applications that
are complements under the Eugenics
movements
and is also intimate in a sense that
said Arthur sort of interweaves his own
personal life history into the book as
well to make it a way more enjoyable
read so it's comprehensive it's
insightful and given that it's also more
of a historical book it's still largely
up to date so I really would recommend
this book
and keeping with the theme of jeans my
next recommendation is Gene machine the
race to discover the secrets of the rib
Sim by fenky ramakrishnan who is a group
leader at the lmb here in Cambridge now
I was fortunate enough to get a signed
copy by him when I was there for the
summer but that's not why it's on my
list of good books is a really important
book to read to have an understanding of
what it's like to be in a sort of
research lab environment
and it still has a lot of technical
um
learning material to learn about the
ribosome if you want to say the ribosome
being a massive complex that is involved
in translation so how you go from mRNA
to protein but it also kind of feels
like exciting reads you get to know what
it's like uh to see scientists complete
and
find novel discoveries and I think it's
hard I've never quite read a book like
it
as the world of science is kind of often
ignored and so if you're thinking I like
biology I want to learn about it then
it's also important to learn about what
it's like to be a scientist especially
in the biology space
a bonus book in this category would be a
crack in creation which is a Memoirs
written by Jennifer baldner who you
probably knows being one of the
discoverers of the Crosby cast iron Gene
editing system
now the next book I also don't have on
me because I believe because I got it
from the library when I first read it
and this is the epigenetics Revolution
by Nessa Kerry I say this book as
someone suggested it's all about
epigenetics these modifications that
happen on top of the genetic sequence so
they could be protein modifications
there could be modifications to DNA and
basically it does sort of influences how
Gene cell reads within the cell and so
this was kind of the book that really
made me go I love bicamistry so
um I have to recommend it for that
reason and I didn't really want to say
much more again it's a good educational
book and it's pretty accessible at least
in my opinion
now my next recommendation has to of
course be a textbook you have to read a
textbook at some point if you want to
learn biology now you can either just
jump straight into the sort of gold
standard textbook the molecular biology
of the cell by Alberts or if you want to
have a more gentle introduction then I
honestly always recommend picking up
revision guides for a level or GCSE
because essentially as I said earlier
you just want to have a foundational
level of biology that you can then build
upon and that's what these books are
great at doing the molecular biology of
the cell is if anything it's too
informative I give you quiz me on it I
wouldn't remember all the facts but it
has everything he could possibly need
again it's probably about out of date
but in terms of the Bare Bones
understanding what the cell structure is
like understanding the core things that
cells do
I you know you can't beat it and
obviously if you buy the most recent
Edition it's quite expensive but again
because you don't have to worry too much
about the latest findings you want to
use it as a sort of starting point you
can totally just get one of the older
editions quite cheaply at least that's
what I did
and I found out okay maybe so it was
fine you can do it too
um
so that brings me on to book six and me
being a researcher on p53
of course I had to suggest this book p53
the gene that cracked the accounts codes
and again this is so this is by Sue
Armstrong and
this has kind of got a journalistic Vibe
so it's similar to G machine and that it
sort of describes the process of
scientific discoveries
and therefore makes it a very
interesting Breeze and again will just
sort of excite you about some of the
things that happen in biological
research and also the struggles that
come with this as well you know the fact
that I'm researching pvc's free shows
that we still haven't really cracked the
codes
um maybe it's low because if I click
baity title
um but I highly recommend that if you're
interested in for example cancer
research
um an alternative book recommendation is
the music of life again it was a library
book that I read so that's more of a
systems Biology book if you're
interested in understanding the
information that the DNA sequence
doesn't provide us yeah again it was
just a interesting book I mean there's
so many great biology books and I've yet
to read them all myself too
so anyway
that's how I would get started if I was
going to begin reading biology books
without my current knowledge so I'm
pretty certain that yeah I would
recommend starting with a textbook or
some revision guides and then budding
yourself up gently and once you've got
these foundational Concepts you can then
pretty much jump into any sort of area
of interest because biology isn't just
about remembering protein names which
again you find in some sense it is but
at the same time it's about having
um
just being aware of the kind of
fundamentals now I've been a bit afraid
about what these fundamentals are and
I'm planning to make a video on that
sometime soon
so yeah just hang about for that
otherwise I hope this video has been
informative and thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening